so now it's your turn to run the hello
world endpoints application go ahead and
import the hello world endpoints project
into eclipse and then you run your app
on localhost and try your app in the web
UI remember you get to it by going to
localhost colon and then your port
number also go ahead and try your app in
the api's explorer and remember you get
to that by going to localhost colon 8080
or whatever your port number is
underscore a H slash API slash explorer
we've tested it out on localhost then go
ahead and run it on appspot
to go to your app on appspot you go to
your app ID appspot.com and when you've
done all those things and your apps
running on appspot go ahead and enter
your app ID here so that you dastardly
can check that it's running